culture
the birthday celebration continues for
cardi b's daughter culture
the 28 year old rapper who is currently
expecting her second child with her
husband offset
had a fun-filled day with her
three-year-old roller coaster rides
included
[Music]
[Laughter]
cardi b took her daughter and her
friends to the american dream
meadowlands mega mall theme park in new
jersey here to have
[Applause]
offset joined in on the fun too while
cardi stayed on the sidelines
straight two strikes
the proud mom stunned in a hot pink
ensemble that showed off her baby bump
accessorizing with hoop earrings and
multiple necklaces
but those necklaces didn't compare to
the one culture got for her birthday
[Music]
yep this three-year-old got iced out for
her special day
the piece featured five charms shaped
like an hermes birken bag
a chanel logo minnie mouse a bow wrapped
heart
and a k initial for culture of course
but the celebrations didn't stop there
happy birthday
happy birthday happy birthday
over the weekend cardian offset gave
their baby girl a princess inspired
birthday party
the over-the-top event included an
animal farm real-life disney princesses
oh snap what is that is that a crab neck
towel
and a crab leg tower wow
and it wouldn't be a princess party
without cake which featured
a carriage and a castle the proud
parents also recently got a look at
their new bundle of joy
i'm about to see first think about
yeah yeah
cardi revealed she and offset are
expecting during her performance at the
bet awards
cardi also shared these beautiful
maternity photos of her growing family
on instagram
i love everything about motherhood in
2019
cardi told et she was already looking to
give culture some siblings
what does it mean to be a mother it
means everything it's
it's like a feeling that it's
indescribable
it's like love joy it's a
switch you know what i'm saying there's
like
an automatic smile so it's everything
everything so if one brings you this
much joy
would you double the joy i want to have
more kids
you do yeah more kids that sounds like
many
you know how whatever my body could take
i feel like the more my baby grows i see
like the different
levels and there's just gonna be
different levels all the time from one
year old
to growing around chasing them making
sure they don't put things in their
mouth
to you know five-year-old when they
start going to school
learning things interacting with other
kids it's always going to be different
levels
yeah yeah yeah of course all right we're
waiting on the next few